Albert Einstein played a key role in
launching quantum mechanics through his
theory of the photoelectric effect but
remained deeply bothered by its
philosophical implications and though
most of us still remember him for
deriving e equals mc-squared
his last great contribution to physics
was actually a 1935 paper co-authored
with his young colleagues Boris Podolsky
and Nathan Rosen regarded as an odd
philosophical footnote well into the
1980s this EPR paper has recently become
central to a new understanding of
quantum physics with its description of
a strange phenomenon now known as
entangled States the paper begins by
considering a source that spits out
pairs of particles each with two
measurable properties each of these
measurements has two possible results of
equal probability let's say 0 or 1 for
the first property and a or B for the
second once a measurement is performed
subsequent measurements of the same
property in the same particle will yield
the same result the strange implication
of this scenario is not only that the
state of a single particle is
indeterminate until it's measured but
that the measurement then determines the
state
what's more the measurements affect each
other if you measure a particle as being
in state one and follow it up with the
second type of measurement you'll have a
50% chance of getting either A or B but
if you then repeat the first measurement
you'll have a 50% chance of getting 0
even though the particle had already
been measured at 1 so switching the
property being measured scrambles the
original result allowing for a new
random value things get even stranger
when you look at both particles each of
the particles will produce random
results but if you compare the two you
will find that they are always perfectly
correlated for example if both particles
are measured at 0 the relationship will
always hold the states of the two are
entangled measuring one will tell you
the other with absolute certainty but
this entanglement seems to defy
Einstein's famous theory of relativity
because there is nothing to limit the
distance between particles if you
measure one in New York at noon and the
other in San Francisco an an a second
later they still give exactly the same
result but if the measurement does
determine the value then this would
require one particle sending some sort
of signal to the other at 13 million
times the speed of light which according
to relativity is impossible for this
reason Einstein
dismissed entanglement as kuhkaff de
ferran Birkin or spooky action at a
distance
he decided that quantum mechanics must
be incomplete a mere approximation of a
deeper reality in which both particles
have predetermined States that are
hidden from us supporters of Orthodox
quantum theory led by Niels Bohr
maintained that quantum states really
are fundamentally indeterminate and
entanglement allows the state of one
particle to depend on that of its
distant partner for 30 years physics
remained at an impasse until John Bell
figured out that the key to testing the
EPR argument was to look at cases
involving different measurements on the
two particles the local hidden variable
theories favoured by Einstein Podolsky
and Rosen strictly limited how often you
could get results like one A or B zero
because the outcomes would have to be
defined in advance Bell showed that the
purely quantum approach where the state
is truly indeterminate until measured
has different limits and predicts mixed
measurement results that are impossible
in the predetermined scenario once Bell
had worked out how to test the EPR
argument physicists went out and did it
beginning with John clauser in the 70s
and LNS Bay in the early 80s dozens of
experiments have tested the EPR
prediction and all have found the same
thing
quantum mechanics is correct the
correlations between the indeterminate
states of entangled particles are real
and cannot be explained by any deeper
variable
the EPR paper turned out to be wrong but
brilliantly so by leading physicists to
think deeply about the foundations of
quantum physics it led to further
elaboration of the theory and helped
launch research into subjects like
quantum information now a thriving field
with the potential to develop computers
of unparalleled power
unfortunately the randomness of the
measured results prevents science
fiction scenarios like using entangled
particles to send messages faster than
light so relativity is safe for now but
the quantum universe is far stranger
than Einstein wanted to believe